[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa ya
está conmigo lista en el estudio rosa
pérez más de euros a bienvenida a feliz
jueves ya casi acabando semana y se está
acabando nuestro programa por este año
pero venimos el año que viene más
recargado a rosa vamos a empezar en
chile en un ambiente ya políticamente
tenso esto de cara a la segunda vuelta
de las presidenciales el próximo domingo
rosa el domingo 19 en ese contexto tal y
como titula el país vamos a ver una
investigación prueba que el padre del
candidato chileno jose antonio kast fue
miembro del partido nazi exacto de raúl
pues como comentábamos no una gota más a
esta polarización ya este ambiente tan
tenso de cara esta segunda vuelta de las
presidenciales chilenas y como decías
este artículo lo que trata es que en la
periodista mauricio babe el barahona
accedió a un documento del archivo
federal de alemania que demuestra que el
padre de josé antonio kast llamado
michael cast o alguien que coincide con
su nombre lugar y fecha de nacimiento se
afilió al partido y poco antes de
cumplir los 18 años en 1942 en plena
segunda guerra mundial y bien lo que
sucede con estas informaciones es que
contradicen la versión dada por el
presidenciable chileno jose antonio kast
hasta el momento él siempre ha dicho que
su padre fue a luchar con el ejército
nazi con el ejército alemán porque en
ese momento debía hacer el servicio
militar obligatorio y lo que señala este
artículo es que si bien ciertamente
ciertamente el servicio militar era
obligatorio no lo era afiliarse al
partido nazi y bien como decíamos este
tema no es nuevo ya ha salido en campaña
de hecho su contrincante de cara a esta
segunda vuelta el izquierdista gabriel
boric le dijo en el debate previo a la
primera vuelta de estas elecciones
migrar es un derecho y a veces también
una tragedia tu padre mismo fue un
migrante después de haber combatido en
el ejército nazi viena en raúl pues un
tema
delicado bien polémico vamos a ver
también cómo se desarrolla esta segunda
vuelta no aquí vamos a hoy vamos a hacer
un especial en france 24 así es rosa
bueno ahora cambiamos de tema vamos con
el diario le monde en francia que
publica una investigación sobre el
naufragio 27 personas en el canal de la
mancha el pasado 24 noviembre también
que pues por supuesto resaltamos aquí en
nuestro programa y titula naufragio en
la mancha los migrantes habían llamado a
los servicios de rescate pero qué pasó
se trata de nuevo de una investigación
que contradice las versiones dadas hasta
el momento en este caso por el gobierno
francés y es que recordemos que el 24 de
noviembre como comentábamos 27 personas
perdieron la vida en el canal de la
mancha cuando naufragó su embarcación
hasta ahora el gobierno francés había
dicho que la alerta la dio una
embarcación pesquera cuando navegaba por
las aguas francesas pero muy próximas a
las aguas británicas sin embargo ahora
esta investigación que ha hablado con
testigos cercanos a las víctimas que
fallecieron también ha revisado las
listas de las llamadas que se dieron
hasta en ese momento pues ha demostrado
como las personas en esta embarcación
pues intentaron
con los servicios de emergencia algo que
también relataron los dos únicos
supervivientes del naufragio a la medio
kurdo rota rosa y bueno volvemos a
cambiar ahora de temas saltemos y vamos
a meternos en el metaverso aparte las
limitaciones de conexión internet que
sabemos que también son muchas hablamos
de casarse en este mundo usted se
casaría en el metaverso rosa pues no lo
sé en todo caso tampoco sé si me casaría
goles la pregunta
pero lo que señala este artículo es que
de momento ninguna pareja ha decidido
casarse exclusivamente en el metaverso
al menos a ninguna pareja lo ha pedido a
las distintas compañías que organizan
estos eventos virtuales excitadas por
este artículo sin embargo relata este
texto el caso de una pareja que ya de
por sí se conoció online por un evento
virtual que organizó la compañía para lo
que trabaja para la que trabajan ambos
miembros de la pareja y decidieron pues
ofrecer también este evento de forma
virtual y por ejemplo una dama de honor
y un amigo del novio pudieron
personificarse en la boda y dijeron que
pues poder seguirlo de forma virtual con
avatares fue una experiencia mucho más
inmersiva que no haberlo seguido por
zoom en todo caso según señala este
artículo este es un negocio floreciente
que tiene pues límite hacer puede ser
inexplorable y cerramos con la lista de
the gardian de las palabras
peor pronunciadas rosas ya tengo miedo
sobre todo nosotros periodistas que
estamos en programas envió cuánto no
hemos pronunciado mal exacta raúl por
suerte esta es una lista elaborada por
una organización que monitorea la
televisión estadounidense así que no nos
incluimos de momento en las personas que
hemos cometido estos errores al menos no
los han visto a nosotros este ejemplo
que es pero en todo caso te voy a hacer
un pequeño test a ver cómo lo superamos
a ver no sé si has visto la cantante que
aparecía en la imagen que veíamos aquí
algún anuncio como pronunciaría ser su
nombre ok bueno yo diría billy joel es
perfecta ok pase seguimos por la ciudad
donde se celebró la cob 26 este año
maravilloso y terminamos con la variante
del coronavirus del 19 como se llama
esta nueva variante omicron bueno raúl
me gradué de graduar este perfecto
parecería incluso que estuviera
preparado a bueno rosa no está preparado
pero pues digamos que me he preparado
muy bien para poder hacer este programa
y decir todos estos hombres sin alma
rosa muchísimas gracias entonces por
revista de prensa armemos o mañana con
más vamos a pasar ahora allá me ves que
me enredo vamos a pasar ahora a hablar
con nuestro primer invitado del día